the media melting down after the Durham
report exposed that the FBI and doj had
quote no justification to launch the
Trump Russia probe the press that
endlessly pushed the phony narrative
that Donald Trump was a secret Russian
spy and his campaign was colluding with
Moscow now looked like complete fools
you would think that they would turn in
their Pulitzer prizes and apologize to
the American people nope not a chance
the former president had predicted that
Durham's probe would uncover quote the
crime of the Century doesn't look like
it actually did that terms the whole
thing is predicated on it's like a
rabbit hole conspiracy his conspiracy
theories while walking through the
fevered swamps of trumpism
well
ended in
probably a career ending reputational
damage this was a whole big nothing four
years I don't know how many millions of
dollars I don't know how many people how
many of his friends he hired in his
office to do what
basically blatantly false report
Durham's report also finding that the
FBI gave markedly different treatment to
the Clinton and Trump campaigns and
ignored Hillary's plan to tie Trump to
Putin in order to distract from her
email Scandal the special counsel
uncovering that both Barack Obama and
Joe Biden knew about Hillary's Dirty
Deeds they got briefed on Clinton's
Shaley scheme Shady scheme to link Trump
to Russia but still pushed the collusion
hoax anyway
shameful
so here and now the Crooked
investigators are running for cover
what you have with John Durham is like
it's a big fat nothing this is a
predictable sad ending to an
investigation that never should have
taken place I vehemently disagree with
uh with Mr Durham's characterizations of
what we did in the report and it's it's
very simple he he betrays a deep
misunderstanding of not only what we
knew at the time but how we make these
decisions
okay so Jesse I'll start with you so
Hillary Clinton puts together the deal
pays for the dossier the dossier uh she
ends up getting fined because she uses
it as a legal expense instead of a
campaign contribution she started this
whole thing and Barack Obama Joe Biden
knew about it and the the media on the
left is saying that this is all a
conspiracy and that's a waste of money
no wonder you didn't put anybody in
prison you'd have to put the entire
Democratic party in prison for this and
I didn't expect prison because I look at
this thing and look at who Durham didn't
even interview he didn't interview
McCabe he did an interview Comey he
didn't interview Glenn Simpson Mark
Elias Peter strzok this isn't a real
investigation and Durham didn't even
subpoena James Comey so if you're going
to do a real investigation and not
subpoena the FBI director it's a joke so
do you realize the FBI lied to the media
and then the media reported the FBI lies
then the FBI guys get fired then they
get hired by the media to tell more lies
and then the media is just happy that no
one went to prison for lying do you
actually think any of these people in
those montages read the Durham report it
doesn't look like they read it at all
and I was walking into Fox today and I
see this Chiron at the bottom of the
screen it says Durham says the FBI
treated Trump and Hillary differently
really I mean Hillary bleached her
server and smashed blackberries with
hammers and then they tried to put Trump
in prison for obstruction think about
that yeah so at the end of the day you
have Joe Biden and Hillary Clinton
coming back from Europe China and the
Middle East with boatloads full of cash
and Trump is the bad guy now the
Republicans are out there saying that oh
when we get in there we need to get rid
of the FBI that's never going to happen
what they need to do is this they need
to appoint a loyalist as FBI director
kind of the way that JFK appointed his
brother to run the justice department
you either need a loyalist or you need
some guy that you have so much dirt on
that he wouldn't even try anything you
know the amazing part of it is that
there will be uh no indictments this is
the end of it they can say look we tried
Dan checko we tried Sussman there were
acquittals we got one low-level guy
Kevin Kleinman who was a lawyer who pled
guilty to altering a document he's
practicing law uh can American people
even have faith in the justice system
and the Democrats talk about threat to
democracy is the Deep State the biggest
threat to demise I mean as I said the
other day on America's Newsroom I might
owe Jason Chaffetz an apology for making
fun of his book that came out a few
years ago I was made from the title I
thought it was a little over dramatic
but I think that you look at this and
what's strange to me and what strikes me
the most is that all of Trump's enemies
Alvin Bragg the partisans at the FBI
Hillary Clinton everything they do is an
overreach and it just makes him stronger
now they had to go through a hell of a
lot and you also think about the younger
people the staff or not even necessarily
younger but people who were just kind of
on the periphery then had to get lawyers
they had to be subjected to terrible
years when they would love to have been
serving the country and been focused on
that to have to go through that and you
know the Clinton Administration a lot of
those younger people went through the
same thing because of what Clinton did
with Lewinsky and on and on and that
happens to people in government so you
wonder like who's going to want to serve
but like in Pac-Man you know that game
Pac-Man so he goes along and when he he
eats more fruit he gets stronger it's
like every time they go after the
president he ends up being stronger
because he's like I told you so I told
you it was A Rush of hoax and I'm I
would love to see any reporter who had
one of these sources whether it's Adam
Schiff or maybe not even have to be that
high level doesn't have to be an elected
leader someone that they could have on
their program and say you told me this
this and this that turns out not to be
true explain yourself I mean that would
be great television it would be good
journalism the other thing is that the
report has
shifted the burden of proof to the FBI
so to your question can people trust it
like is there a different set of rules
for people if you are part of the
establishment or the government or on
the Democratic side because not only do
you have this situation with the Russia
hoax you have the hunter Biden
investigation that has been going on for
so long and the security apparatus have
tried to bury the laptop and succeeded
along with the media and now reports
that the IRS is reassigning The
Whistleblower on the hunter Biden thing
so you have to start wondering if there
is two systems you know what is Geraldo
what is the realistic solution going
forward here the American people have
lost faith in the criminal justice
system and I find it fascinating that
the left was saying all this money for
the Durham report what about all the
money for the Mueller report where they
hired all their friends and came up with
nothing but tried to make it sound like
something that we now know from the
Inspector General and Durham was really
nothing I think the biggest significance
of this is that it is an official
acknowledgment after years of probing
that Donald Trump did not collude with
Russia there was never any collusion
that's the bottom line and we can't lose
sight of that in all of the uh the noise
about about politics there was never a
golden shower with a hooker in Moscow is
all made up the steel dossier was bought
and paid for by Yeah by democrats and
the and the overarching effect of it all
is it not only did it erode our faith in
government generally but it was a very
very profound pointed attack at Donald
Trump and it almost got him he was
rattled in the early days this sabotaged
the early days of his presidency and I
think William Barr coming on as attorney
general is what saved the Trump
presidency but this was a real vicious
all-out very effective attack on the on
the newly elected president and it
almost succeeded so you think William
Barr is the hero here oh yeah I do I
think it's the most honest man in
Washington now I would say that there is
no one who could have said what Donald
Trump did and I don't know that he was
so rattled he withstood more than anyone
could but you know what wrap it up Tyrus
well we American people we've been
catfished that's what it is this is a
catfish we had a picture of a beautiful
model that was supposedly Russian
interference and turns out it was not it
was short ugly lying person who made a
lot of money making up lies that's what
the bottom line is and we can't fix it
they're not all the people that didn't
have jobs and they also have the ability
to oversee to make sure that they don't
get in trouble and they're in their
right Administration so what the
American people we have to do is we have
to remember this come vote time you need
to remember that there was a quiet coup
on the last Administration over two
years and they all made millions of
dollars so vote them out of office
they'll be fine because they have the
money but we can't rely on someone in
government to fix our problems the only
ones who can fix our problems is us the
American people vote them out and that's
the only way you're going to get any
kind of rightness back and what is what
was a coup and that is the most horrible
disgusting but the only evidence the
only thing that matters is the American
people we need to vote the right way
next time if I could say one other thing
I meant to say I was thinking that while
I was walking down the street today it
you know they always say it's worse than
Watergate this actually truly is worse
than Watergate yes they found something
that is yeah correction Pac-Man eats
power pellets to get powerful he eats
fruits for points no just please points
so much everyone Hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now